so often we read books or watch videos
or read a blog to learn how to persuade
other people how to close others
negotiate read others it's always about
how can I do something to other people
right so we study other people so much
but I will tell you the most important
subject you and I can study the most
important subject you and I can study is
the person we're going to live with for
the rest of our lives more than any
other person in the world is ourselves
and what I mean by ourselves is how do
you trend not on social media how do
your decisions in life trend do you
study how you trend and we're going to
talk about that today because you know
some of my favorite quotes here I'll
tell you what Aristotle said he said
knowing yourself is the beginning of all
wisdom Aristotle he mentored Alexander
the Great right Rumi and you when will
you begin that long journey into
yourself Ralph Ellison when I discover
who I am I will be free right so instead
of trying to study everybody else and
get them to do what you want for you why
don't you study yourself for you to make
better choices so life will be simpler
so let's study some of these trends here
okay Patrick what do you mean how do you
trend okay so let's look at this pick
the last three crisis that happen in
your life
okay whatever those crisis may be loss
of a loved one a divorce a bankruptcy a
health issue a setback something happier
but ever those three things are okay
write them down on whatever they are
then study how you react it to each one
of them what was your reaction to each
one of them okay is your reaction
bad-mouthing it's their fault it's his
fault it's the company's fault it's
because this it's not my fault I
couldn't do anything this is how I ran
if you study these trends you will
notice there are certain clues about you
okay then you ask yourself the question
do I like how I trend do I like how I
respond to the crisis do I like the
results of the way I respond to crisis
if the answer is yes you keep doing it
but if the answer is every time crisis
happens the way you respond to it is
something that does not bring
fulfillment in your life it's constant
misery and setback then you got to make
a shift to that here's another one I had
a friend of mine that would talk about
relationships you know it's always this
girl's fault no no that one didn't work
out because she's this this one didn't
work out because she's dead I want
didn't work out because she's this
eventually we set then I said listen let
me ask you a question you've been
telling me this about the last five
girls you dated you really want to tell
me it's all these girls problems so if
that's the case what do we need to shift
for us not to have that experience that
goes back to trend health goes in this
the types of people that you argue with
the types of people you don't like the
types of people you don't get along with
make a list of those three people you
don't get along with and ask yourself
what's the trend is it because they push
you too much do they remind you of your
father do they remind you of your mother
do they remind you of somebody do they
remind you of your ex is that the trend
with them they're not your ex so why are
you responding to that so either you're
going to continue having those types of
relationship with these types of people
or if you want to be able to have better
relationship with these folks you need
to make a shift on how you respond to
these folks so now this exercise with
trending it is very fascinating when you
study you let me tell what happened with
me many years ago one of the most
important events that took place in my
life was in August of 3 I got a hold of
these questions that a friend gave me
was 83 questions I got away and I went
to the beach El Matador I mean over the
years I've collect a lot of these
questions but I got a hold of these
questions I went to a matador and it
said somewhere in Malibu I think and I
would go there on Sundays I grab these
questions 6 7 8 hours and every question
was about events that happen in my life
that affected the way I am today right
my personality do it the way I think
today by the time I was done going
through these questions I was so
emotional it was intense I was crying I
was furious with myself I was angry I
was so disappointed with myself
but I was happy with myself I started
accepting myself then I started
realizing the problem
here and the good news is you can fix it
that's the great news about above all
this can be fixed
there are solution for this if I want to
and I did life started changing so so I
decided yours later just a few months
ago to make those questions public on my
website Patrick made David calm and it's
called the ultimate self discovery
questioner let me just put it to you
this way thousands of people have
already taken around the world and we've
gone thousands email if you've sent us
email we haven't gone back to it because
we've been bombarded with emails and we
haven't had a chance to get back to
everybody but here's some of the ones I
want to reach you on what happened with
some of these folks who took these
question and how they responded to it
here's the first one this is from guru
grind I will not mention the name
I took your exists extensive question
and it really made me answer some
questions I wouldn't have answered
before it really made me think and dig
deep into some deep rooted issues a like
I have tried to bury how many of us have
tried to bury deep buried rooted issues
that cause limiting beliefs in our lives
that's preventing us to live a fulfilled
life right here's another one
I'll save the best for last here's one
from Portugal I do believe this type of
email comes often to this inbox bye
thank you for the extreme iOpener that
was a question I find you via Facebook
and your website by accident and I feel
like a lucky bastard in my mind I didn't
think it was possible to get emotional
and cry when answering these questions
but in fact it happened so many
different emotions in just a few
questions I want to hide the answer
somewhere only I can have access to but
I don't want to destroy them because I
feel I might need to read them again in
the future to remind me of these
feelings and what answering that did to
me but I don't want anyone else to see
them or feel or I feel they would know
too much about me is that not
interesting to study you is that not
interesting to study you what good for
you for sending this email to us you
know who you are and this last one is
from I'll read this is from India and it
says about an hour ago colleague of mine
placed a link on my Facebook channel to
our company sales tips you know what's
up group and then after scrolling to
your facebook down entry by your video
pose I discovered a question a button I
subscribe
after switching my phone to airplane
mode she followed all the directions in
the video after switching my phone to
airplane mode setting up my digital box
to the Songhai suggested which is
Symphony number four in a major and I
found the relaxing seat of my home and
started with a lot of anticipation all
set to go I started reading the first
set of questions instantly my breath
stoked little by little by the time I
had completed section one and reading
the reflection I was crying like a baby
to give some inside info I split up last
December with my partner one month after
that I find out my father's lifeless
body arranged his funeral and haven't
shed a tear during the entire process 15
sessions of therapy did not give me
where these questions got me and I'm
only talking about first two sections
right now I truly the answers to this
question it does tell you a lot about
who you are so thank you for that and
now calm down and I wipe the mascara off
my cheeks I will try to actually take a
pen and write down the answer to the
questions that I've been avoiding for
years and years you see first of all I
applaud all of you that have gone
through these questionnaires and
thousands of you that have sent it to us
again we haven't gone through all of
them but we will we will read through
all of them because it's important that
you want to share your experience with
us if you watching this video if you
watch the entire video by this time if
you truly want to figure out your
capacity your abilities the clarity for
you to have in life and what you're able
to do with your calling you got to take
a step back and study you you got to
take a step back and study your trends
and many times in your life and your
when if something happens in your life
this is how you talk to yourself when
some happens you say normally you
typically respond to it this way but let
me tell you something after doing the
question and figuring out who you're on
what your trends are I would suggest you
sort of responding to it this way don't
say anything just relax I totally
understand you feel that way I'm sorry I
made you feel that way I will work on it
or whatever maybe that's awareness and
it changes all your relationships in
your life so my suggestion to you while
you're watching this if you haven't
taken the ultimate self discovery
questionnaire go to Patrick Brady become
the link is going to be somewhere on
here maybe on the bottom description go
to it get the questionnaire print it out
go to quite place
the directions to the tea go through the
questioner then send us an email let us
know how that experience was for you but
I could tell you if you study or trends
life can change for you just like it did
for me thanks for watching